so captain marvel just wrapped up its
filming and in light of that and since
many of you have asked for it I thought
to do a video on the origin and powers
of Captain Marvel actress brie Larson
will be taken on the character Carol
Danvers and the mantle of Captain Marvel
in the upcoming film in March 2019 so
hopefully this gives you some background
information about Captain Marvel and
some excitement going into the film also
if you want to stay up to date with
Captain Marvel Avengers 4 and everything
happening in the MCU be sure to
subscribe to my channel so to start off
Captain Marvel is not the actual
character that brie Larson will be
playing in the film the character is
Carol Danvers and eventually she goes on
to take the mantle of Captain Marvel in
order to fully explain Captain Marvel's
origin story for you I have to explain
the origin of the first Captain Marvel
who is Marvel Marvel is an agent of the
alien race the creep in the comics a
Kree known as Yan raagh had made several
attempts to try and kill Marvell
although Marvel did not know that it was
Yan robbed his trying to kill him in one
battle jaan raghav out to kill Marvel
but then a plane crashes between them
and blows up immediately stopping the
fight Marvel goes to investigate the
pilot who of course is dead and he finds
his wallet and what he calls his
identification papers he discovers that
the pilot was dr. Walter Lawson and that
he is an expert on missile-guidance and
was on his way to NASA in Cape Canaveral
Marvel decides to take on the identity
of dr. Walter Lawson in an attempt to
try and find out who was trying to kill
him this is where Carol Danvers comes in
were first introduced to her in 1968
Marvel superheroes volume 1 issue 13 we
learned that Danvers was a former
officer in the Air Force in an extremely
skilled fighter pilot and also a former
agent in the CIA Danvers is hired as the
security director of NASA which is where
she meets Marvel who is disguised as dr.
Walter Lawson Marvel ended up saving
Carol Danvers his life along with
everybody else at NASA when a Kree robot
that NASA had been studying was
reactivated Marvel defeated the robot
and the press dubbed him captain
Marvel after Marvel saved Carol Danvers
his life a romance started between the
two of them young raagh learned of this
romance and kidnapped Carol Danvers in
an attempt to lure Marvel into a trap
when Marvel shows up jaan raghav as a
machine called the psyche magnetron to
attack him this machine is actually a
forbidden cream machine and ends up
exploding in which Marvel shields
Danvers from the blast
this caused Danvers to absorb some of
Marvel's DNA essentially her genetic
structure fused with marvel's genetic
structure and her DNA became now both
human and cream Danvers was hurt from
the explosion but when she recovered she
found out she had some powers so there's
a brief explanation of her origin let's
now talk about the powers that she has
for starters Carol Danvers being a spy
in the CIA and a top fighter pilot she
already has some deadly skills as a
human with hand-to-hand combat and a
wide variety of assault weapons but
let's start with her actual superpowers
that most of the regular superheroes
have that list includes superhuman
strength stamina and durability and
speed then a superpower that only some
superheroes have and that is the ability
to fly and now for some superpowers that
are actually pretty unique she has the
ability to harness and control energy
she can fire energy concussive blasts
out of her hands that's pretty cool on
its own but combine that with her
ability to absorb energy when she
absorbs energy the energy blast that she
shoots from her hands become
significantly more powerful if she
absorbs enough energy these energy
blasts can be as strong as a nuclear
explosion
good luck vanos her part Creed DNA
enables her to be resistant to most
toxins and poisons and not to mention
she has a sixth sense that they call
cosmic awareness essentially this lets
her detect any threat or change that
could affect her from anywhere in the
universe and to top it all off she once
absorbed the energy of a white hole
which gave her the power to control
stellar energies and half control over
heat the electromagnetic spectrum and
gravity oh and not to mention that she
can travel at the speed of light survive
in the vacuum of space and she can
withstand and deal a strike with the
force of a 90
2-ton wait she can knock you out
ultimately down the line when Marvel
dies Carol Danvers officially takes on
the mantle of Captain Marvel so not a
bad list of powers and certainly much
needed if she's going to go against the
mad Titan Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet so there's an explanation on
the origin of Captain Marvel and the
powers that she has what do you all
think is she strong enough to take on
the mad Titan Thanos with the Infinity
Gauntlet let me know your thoughts in
the comments below
and of course be sure to like this video
and subscribe to my channel so you can
stay up to date on Captain Marvel
Avengers 4 and all things related to
Marvel DC and superhero thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]